wie bitte kam das legendäre signal von
einem raumschiff das war wirklich im
wahrsten sinne des wortes war im august
1977 registrierte einen us teleskop an
extrem mysteriöses signal stärker als
alle anderen signale zuvor
bis heute rätseln fachleute jetzt will
der wissenschaftler den ursprung des
signals endlich entschlüsselt haben
klicks umsatz in future gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich der wahnsinn unser
podcast in den top-10 wissenschafts
podcast hammer hätte ich so nicht
erwartet und jetzt gibt es ja den
podcast mit mehrwert also ich erzähle
wie mir der schnabel gewachsen ist immer
noch ein bisschen mehr zum thema also
hier unter mir geht es im podcast und
vergesst das abonnieren nicht der link
ist auch in der video beschreibung und
dem ersten kommentar es handelt sich
wohl um eines der mysteriösesten signale
die wir menschen bei unserer intensiven
suche nach außerirdischen zivilisation
jeweils angefangen haben und jetzt
könnte sein ursprung möglicherweise
gelöst sein
die rede ist vom sogenannten v signal
dass der fachwelt bereits seit 44 jahren
kopfzerbrechen bereitet nun hat sich der
us physiker james beckford ausgiebig mit
dem rätsel beschäftigt dazu hat er alle
bereits vorhandenen daten neu
ausgewertet und seine hypothese ist
wirkt die spektakulär geht davon aus
dass das geheimnisvolle signal von einem
energie strahl stammt mit dessen hilfe
eine außerirdische zivilisation ein
raumschiff antrag diese idee ist alles
andere als abgefahren an diesem konzept
um objekte im weltall zu bewegen tüfteln
auch raumfahrt ingenieurinnen und
ingenieure auf der erde
sie haben den plan miniatur sonden zum
zwerg stern proxima centauri und dem
dort sterne nächsten planeten zu senden
die säge dieser miniatur sollten könnten
mit lesern von der erde beschleunigt
werden so oder so ähnlich könnte auch
das raumschiff der außerirdischen
zivilisation angetrieben werden steckt
also außerirdisches leben hinter dem
mysteriösen bau signal wie genau der
us-physiker auf diese hypothese kommt
und was dahinter steckt darüber spreche
ich in diesem video
angefangen wurde das warnsignal im jahr
1977 vom seti vor
die riemen und zwar mit hilfe des big
ihr teleskops der ohio state university
ganze 72 sekunden konnte das rätselhafte
signal eingefangen werden das aus dem
sternbild des schützen kam etwa zwölf
grad südlich der scheiben ebene der
milchstraße und 19 grad lässt sich des
galaktischen zentrums das radiosignal
auf 1420 megahertz war damals wirklich
aufregend für die gesamte fachwelt denn
es entspricht der frequenz die nicht nur
fachleute sondern auch laien weltweit
besonders ins visier nehmen und zwar bei
der suche nach intelligenten
außerirdischen signalen
denn klar ist wasserstoff ist das
element das im universum am häufigsten
vorkommt und energie nicht nur
absorbiert sondern auch aus sendet in
der fachwelt ist von der sogenannten h1
linie die rede
diese wasserstoff linie bezeichnet die
charakteristische radiostrahlung des
neutralen wasserstoffs und so notierte
der astronom cherryman auf seinen daten
ein einziges wort wow
fest stand jedenfalls schnell dort wo es
herkommt befindet sich kein auffälliger
stern stattdessen nur sehr weit
entfernte und schwache sterne
seit diesem tag dem 15 august 77 rätseln
fachleute also woher dieses signal kommt
30 tage lang suchten die fachleute immer
weiter an derselben stelle aber das
signal hat sich seitdem nie wieder
wiederholt auch die frage ob das signal
schon am tag zuvor oder bereits seit
längerer zeit da gewesen war ist noch
offen und es sind wirklich viele und
deutlich empfindlicher radioteleskope
mit deren hilfe man sich seitdem auf die
suche nach einer wiederholung des
signals gemacht hatte doch bislang
leider erfolglos weder dort noch an
einer anderen stelle des himmels wurde
noch einmal etwas vergleichbares
gefunden
relativ klar scheint aber zu sein dass
es sich eher nicht um ein natürliches
irdisch signal handelt dafür sprechen
einige punkte unter anderem spricht die
länge von 72 sekunden dafür dass das
signal mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit aus
dem weltraum kommen denn dabei handelt
es sich genau um die zeit die eine radio
quelle am himmel aufgrund der
erdrotation benötigt um sich durch den
empfangsbereich der antenne zu ziehen
von einer irdischen quelle würde man
eher ein konstantes signal erwarten ein
flugzeug dagegen würde sich wohl
deutlich kürzer als rund 70 sekunden im
empfangsbereich aufhalten
was dazukommt der frequenzbereich um die
sogenannte h1 linie ist für die
radioastronomie geschützt und kein
zugelassener sender benutzt ihn auch
kosmische partikel die eine störung im
empfänger auslösen können schalten wohl
aus denn auch dafür sind die 72 sekunden
viel zu lang zudem würde man hier auch
ein anderes profil erwarten und nicht
das gemessene charakteristische glocken
kurven profil die liste der möglichen
ursachen ist also lang doch fachleute
weltweit konnten bisher vieles davon
ausschließen planeten und oder
asteroiden wasserstoffgas oder auch
satelliten konnten bisher mit absolut
sehr hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
ausgeschlossen werden jetzt gibt es eine
neue mögliche erklärungs möglichkeit und
die stammt eben von dem us physiker
james benford zwar hat er keine neuen
signale aufgespürt doch die alten daten
des v6 malz noch einmal genauer ins
visier genommen und demnach scheint es
gar nicht abwegig zu sein dass das
mysteriöse signal achtung von einem
außerirdischen raumschiffs stammen
könnte konkret könnte das signal benford
zufolge von einem energie strahl stammen
dieses könnte von einer außerirdischen
intelligenz genutzt werden um sich mit
hilfe eines raumschiffes fortzubewegen
ein konzept das auch auf der erde
bereits ausgetüftelt wird konkret denken
fachleute darüber nach mit hilfe von
lasern das proxima centauri system zu
erreichen bereits vor fünf jahren 2016
hatte der us physiker viele blumen
vorgeschlagen sondern mithilfe
gigantischer sonnensegel so stark zu
beschleunigen dass die interstellare
entfernung in überschaubarer zeit
überbrücken können wenig später wurde
das projekt breakthrough star schott ins
leben gerufen dass ich genau dieser
vision widmet mit dabei waren und sind
auch mark zuckerberg stephen hawking und
der harvard physiker ivy bridge den
haben wir ja hier auch bei clixoom
interviewt auch bei der nasa gibt es
überlegungen dazu zwar deutsche
wissenschaftler hatten vor einiger zeit
dann auch eine idee entwickelt wie
solche weltraumsonden nicht nur in
kurzer zeit unseren nachbarstädten alpha
centauri erreichen könnten sondern dort
dann auch abbremsen könnten
das war bislang nämlich noch eine echte
herausforderung die sonne die von den
beiden max planck forschern
vorgeschlagen wurde könnte dank ihres
sonnensegels mit fast
fünf der lichtgeschwindigkeit alpha
centauri oder proxima centauri anpeilen
die beiden sternensysteme liegen nah
beieinander
dank der strahlung der sterne könnte sie
vor ort auch abbremsen und dann dort im
system bleiben so könnte sie dann eben
sogar zu proxima centauri und den
exoplaneten gelenkt werden riesige leser
von der erde aus könnten die sonden auf
einen bruchteil der lichtgeschwindigkeit
beschleunigen in manchen studien ist
hier vom 5 in manchen von 20 prozent die
rede so könnte das proxima system
jedenfalls immer rund 20 jahren erreicht
werden und das gilt auch für alpha
centauri bei seiner analyse hat james
balfour drei merkmale des mysteriösen
bau signals ins visier genommen die
frequenz die dauer des signals und die
leistungsdichte der physiker fasst in
seinem bericht zusammen dass es sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist dass das signal
sein ursprung auf der erde also bei uns
menschen hat denn das signal wurde in
einer bandbreite gesendet die eben
international offiziell geschützt ist
und in der irdische emission untersagt
sind weiterhin komplett zu dem ergebnis
dass das signal tatsächlich zu den
stärksten spezifischen signalen gehört
die von menschen jemals eingefangen
werden kommt das signal habe das
hintergrundrauschen laut ben folds
analyse auf seinem höhepunkt um das 32
fache überschritten und ein weiterer
punkt den der physiker festhält dass
pikiert teleskop war zur zeit der ortung
mit der erdrotation gekoppelt 38
sekunden wurde es demnach mit dem
antennen strahl geortet also nicht nur
empfangen und diese dauer entspricht
auch der dauer die fachleute bei einer
bewegung himmlischer und astronomischer
quellen erwarten würden aber auch an
dieser stelle muss noch einmal
festgehalten werden dass nicht klar ist
wie lange das signal tatsächlich
stattgefunden hat und das ist noch nicht
alles in der aktuellen analyse von james
benford der hat sich einen weiteren
aspekt genauer angeschaut und zwar die
quelle des signals die in weiter
entfernung verortet wird dass das signal
seit seiner entdeckung vor vielen jahren
danach nie wieder aufgespürt werden gott
bedeutet er als hinweis darauf dass
seine hypothese stimmen könnte
dazu schreibt er sollte das signal
tatsächlich einem energie strahl
entstammen der eine sonde von einem
planeten zu einem
stern beschleunigte zur befand sich der
ursprungs planet zu dieser zeit
vermutlich bereits weit von der sonne
selbst entfernt auf diese weise könnte
die erde zufällig ein energie lag dieses
strahlen abbekommen haben da sich sterne
schließlich relativ zueinander bewegen
ein neuer und vielversprechender ansatz
also für die suche nach außerirdischem
leben denn klar ist ein energie strahl
der interstellare sonden oder gar
raumschiffe antreibt ist vergleichsweise
einfach aufzuspüren deswegen fordert
james beckford weitere durchmusterungen
des sternenhimmels im laser und
mikrowellenbereich er ist optimistisch
weitere energie lex und damit indizien
für außerirdisches leben aufzuspüren wir
bleiben natürlich dran am thema und mehr
dazu gibt es jetzt hier auf die ohren im
podcast also anklicken anhören und
abonnieren
einen der zehn top wissenschafts podcast
einen der zehn top wissenschafts bot
cast klicks um science and future also
unbedingt mal anhören bis dann bleibt
dran